another one from natural lawson so there
are two types of lawsons
i'm getting very full gentlemen we're
nearly done we're nearly done
there are there is the natural lawsons
which is has tends to have more healthy
options healthy snacks healthy
uh meals it's actually pretty good it's
a pretty pretty cool marketing strategy
um and so they have their own brand of
stuff and this is the cranberry cookies
with
gaba cranberry cookie gaba gaba as it
says isn't gaba like the stuff they put
in energy drinks
uh oh yeah it is isn't it yeah
cookie that's what it says in japanese
very good japanese hungry jose
i was looking for gaba and i was like
where's gaba literally at the top
it says gabba gabba you're gonna point
out the camera
they literally spoke gabba in english
yeah
[Music]
acid so amino is exactly what this is
supposed to be healthy so
uh what is it like yeah so the stuff in
natural austin is way more healthy so it
should be healthier
so one of these is is that one
one bag 65 calories is that right 7.5
grams
oh that might be i'll just give it a
shot anyway you can tell me joey i'll
hand it to you
okay there you go
okay okay that's uh this whoa this looks
like a
diet this looks like a diet this is a
velveeta yeah this looks like a diet
snack it looks like a diet bar
how many calories a bag or like what is
it uh so it's per
meal meal yeah which is 17
and a half grams oh this is 35 grams so
okay so
two so there's a hundred hundred so half
a half a bag is 65 kilo
calories that's not bad yeah first for
like what looks to be like a very heavy
snack
yeah so let's have a taste
that's literally like a belvita it is a
belvita what's a bell beetle
it's like the the diet like cookies or
diet biscuits with like
like it's all you have in every country
yeah this tastes like something like my
grandma would have had
you know like something like it's like
grandma can i have some snacks and she's
like here you go
actually i quite like it i like that
tastes nice i actually if i had a
natural lawson's closer to me i'd
probably get that
yeah that's actually fun cranberry
favorite stuff is actually really good
i'm taking that home with me a little
ziplock bag
fantastic should we talk about some of
the stuff at the front
okay yeah i want to talk about this i
really like these these are
the ramune flavored um
what is candy candy i have an ancient
video on my channel from like
six years ago where i bought like a box
of those candy right
and i said to myself would i be able to
change ramune candy back to ramune
was it
yeah so what i did was i emptied out
like 30 of these
i don't put them into a bowl no no no no
no no no i emptied like 30 of these into
a bowl and i
crushed them into a powder and then i
mixed it with the carbonated water to
see if we'd go back into a ramune
spoilers it doesn't go back into ramen
um
i've only ever had the drink a few times
it's quite nice but i mean
it's basically what how do you how would
you describe ramen it's basically like a
japanese uh lemonade right yeah japanese
wow yeah i love these is this this you
love this
i do i grew up with this [ __ ] yeah okay
it's like eating a kid
i i i eat this and i'm like i taste a
childhood i never had
no wonder you got like 10 gone because
you're [ __ ] eating kids [ __ ] all the
time
probably what were you drinking like
breast milk still all the time like
what's going on
like i would secretly i would eat this
what connor has they're right there
chocolate babies i love these
these are great these are like these are
terrible though because like
you think you're not eating a lot of
chocolate because it's so [ __ ] dense
i i look at this and i thought it was
going to be a tic tac
that's that right the first time i just
tried it i thought it was kicked out it
looks like a tic tac
and then you bite into it and it's just
it's just like chocolate
it's pure chocolate chocolate as well
though it's the most inoffensive
chocolate that it's like
it's the good chocolate you would eat as
a kid
there's a tag at the bottom there was a
tag you did it
yeah literally just tic tac chocolate
version yeah pretty much
it makes chocolate way too easy to eat
because because you just
the supermarkets have the big versions
yeah and if i get them it's almost
impossible
it's like it's like eating sprinklings
and
oh that's that's my childhood right
there like this big as well tiny
that's my childhood really nice milk
chocolate that's good
the other thing though that is my
childhood is these things
um i hate these they suck you tried
these
no oh yeah you can try it okay so these
they're literally called umaibo which
means tasty stick that's literally what
it's called
okay and it's basically oh god how do
you even explain it so basically there's
like these have been around since like
the [ __ ] 20s like these are ancient
and they're 10 yen each all right
[ __ ] nothing but feel how light that
is these are the space rocks
these are the space raiders of japan i
think this this is because this is
packaged air
yeah if you throw this high enough into
the air it'll just go off this has
no weight at all what's the actual
weight written on the package
uh oh dozens
six grams six grams
but i guarantee i'm pretty sure most of
the grams is the packaging
is this the [ __ ] packaging i'm
literally holding air so i'm
i have the corn portage flavored which
is like cornstarch
dude this this just looks like monster
this just looks like monsters
i've got the cheese one you should try
it
what is this flavor those are the mint i
call flavor the squad roast
this is just monsters crisps yeah isn't
it this is like
monsters crisps if they were made by
space raiders do you have space traders
in australia i've heard of those yeah
all right let's try this
there's a big watcher it takes away all
the moisture in your mouth
yeah it's a monster's crisp it's just a
what's it yeah it's a big what's it mine
this is just use it to say
honestly i mean i could i can understand
why you that was your childhood
americans this is a cheeto
i mean honestly dude like imagine like
you're like a five-year-old right
yeah you're giving like a hundred yen of
like just you know pocket money from
your grandmas of course you're buying 10
years i'm buying 10 of these
like these these [ __ ] are gonna
fill me up for until dinner honestly
i mean who who doesn't love [ __ ]
whatsits or monsters chris or whatever